hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 56
hört zu und spricht nach
ich mag die schweiz weil hier alles
sauber ist
ich mag
schweiz weil hier alles sauber ist
in der schweiz stört mich dass man immer
so viel planen muss
ein vorteil ist dass es fast keine
kriminalität gibt
ich lebe gern
schweiz weil es hier sicher ist
weil es hier sicher ist
ich finde toll dass das schulsystem sehr
gut ist
die schweiz ist zu schön weil es viele
berge und seen gibt
die schweiz ist sehr schön weil es viele
mich stört dass die schweizer oft
gestresst sind
mir gefällt in der
schweiz dass hier so viele kulturen und
ausländer zusammenleben
mir gefällt die
der schweiz das je so viele kulturen und
ausländer zusammenleben
ich finde es unanständig wenn man zu
spät kommt
die schweizer werden wütend wenn man sie
warten lässt
die schweizer wie
wütend wenn man sie warten lässt
ich habe eine stunde auf dich gewartet
warum bist du zu spät daniel warum bist
du zu spät daniel entschuldigung ich bin
zu spät weil ich den bus verpasst habe
entschuldigung ich bin zu spät weil ich
den bus verpasst habe
in der schweiz sind die leute manchmal
distanziert
distanziert die busse züge und trams
fahren immer pünktlich die busse züge
und trams waren immer pünktlich weiter
sind pflichtbewusst pünktlich
organisiert und genau
die schweizer sind pflichtbewusst
pünktlich organisiert und genau
in der schweiz ist die lebensqualität
hoch in der schweiz ist die
lebensqualität hoch
in der schweiz sind die löhne sehr hoch
es ist schwierig in der schweiz freunde
zu finden
in der schweiz gibt es wenig
arbeitslosigkeit in der schweiz gibt es
wenig arbeitslosigkeit
in der schweiz gibt es vier jahreszeiten
den sommer den herbst den winter und den
frühling
in der schweiz gibt es vier jahreszeiten
den sommer den herbst den winter und den
frühling
das politische system in der schweiz ist
eine direkte demokratie
die schweiz ist ein reiches land
die lebenshaltungskosten in der schweiz
sind sehr hoch man muss viel geld für
die miete
die krankenkasse und die lebensmittel
ausgeben
die lebenshaltungskosten in der schweiz
sind sehr hoch man muss viel geld für
die miete
die krankenkasse und die lebensmittel
ausgeben